alex i'm just your media buyer but i
didn't know you care so much about the
fake guru problem
ultimate elitism wrapped up in all this
fake
moralizing trash exactly that's what
i've been saying forever they're
stealing people's money right
but in modern times a bunch of scum get
together and organize themselves
to go fool the masses to follow failure
yeah exactly because they can't compete
with success i don't care how much money
or power
you give a hunchback crohn with a
diseased brain alex as your media buyer
i have to tell you you can't talk like
that susan will never let you
i've got a big vocabulary but i'm sorry
sometimes the volgoth
the vulgar the barbarian way is the way
to say it
okay buddy i didn't know you're so
heated about the gurus man
and i guess in the final equation as
upset as i get watching you hurt the
innocent that's what matters
is that you'll never never defeat the
human spirit
you'll never defeat god you'll
never alex alex alex calm pal buddy
oh my god okay okay okay hey
guys we have to go to break we have to
go to break this is too much this is too
bad humanity
okay
wow i'm a bit tired working two jobs to
pay off the 10 million dollar studio
it's exhausting i just want to just
chill out today make a shorter video
less more casual video
and just watch some tick tock you know
check into what the kids are into these
days you know
here let's learn some finance look this
guy seems good he's uh teaching personal
finance let's see don't fall for fake
robin hood gurus okay
what's this guy about if i see one more
person on my tick tock timeline giving
up professional advice because they have
hundreds and thousands and sometimes
even millions of dollars in their robin
hood account i swear i'm gonna rip out
my hair
that's not how you make consistent
income in the stock market consistent
income comes from proper risk management
i'm gonna fair enough danny i like your
message dude i'm gonna let's let's look
into more more of this man don't fall
for fake robin and gurus
promoting terrible risk management no
risk management okay cool
oh what's this it's gets even more views
2.8 million this must be one of his big
videos here
you're gonna turn 100 into a million
dollars in one year
just by doing this what we're gonna oh
danny i thought you had something i
thought me and you had something
together
to do is i'm gonna teach you how to
trade options in the stock market with
proper risk management and trading whoa
you were saying earlier that no one
knows proper risk management but you're
going to tell us how to get 100
100 to 1 million in one year okay let's
see
large companies such as apple microsoft
facebook tesla amazon and so on
no penny stocks no small stocks we're
going to trade large companies and we're
going to aim for 20
return every single week in the options
world it is very doable to do it so
we're gonna
a 20 in a week very doable boys
very doable risk management to do is 100
turns into 120 then 144 then 172 by week
4 doing 20
consistent gains and by the end of the
year a million dollars in your account
this is very doable but you danny what's
gone wrong
buddy what do you mean it's very doable
you know it's not
weren't you just calling out the fake
robin hood gurus who aren't teaching
proper risk management you think making
20
a week is proper risk management buddy
have to learn how to trade
options with proper risk management and
i'm here
jeez dude what is this guy on right now
he's probably going to sell a course
right he's going to sell us of course if
he's saying 100
to 1 million he's selling us a course
right teach you strategies on how to do
options and how to do it properly
and how to do it for all beginners if
you know nothing about the stock market
right
all you need to do is click on my
profile subscribe to my website
you get a welcome email with okay let's
go danny enough for the pitch let's see
how much you're charging me
learn investing oh look at that 97
stock options course what a deal make a
million dollars in a year if you invest
97
right here incredible danny devin
but i want to tell you guys that this is
a man who is educating people on
business
finance life principles he may only be
like
i don't know young 20s and he's already
a master of business finance and life
principles dude
that's what he's educating you guys on
these are the people you need to be
listening to
follow my journey copyright
2023. dude this guy
this guy he's not even in 2020 dude this
is a man
not only does he have life experience
well beyond his years
already he knows finance business life
principles but in addition to that
he's three years ahead just in his mind
his mind so far
gone you know into the into the future
guys i i really i'm confused
i used to think that you had to know
something to teach i used to think that
you had to
be somebody in order to teach but
nowadays dude these 20 year olds are
crushing the guru game
they're they don't even have any shame
about it they'll try to coach you by the
time they're out of their diapers dude
they're just hitting puberty and they're
right in their manifesto they can't even
drive a car
and they're already making their click
funnel tiktok has just opened a new
medium for it all
now you don't even have to try to prove
any of this stuff you just get on a
quick tick tock say make a million
dollars to get three million hits
it's insane dude a lot of people are
gonna lose a lot of money from people
like this
but i think it's just so funny that this
guy's like don't fall for these robin
hood gurus
at the beginning of his little tick tock
career and by the end of it he's like
hey
you want to make a million dollars come
buy my course
come by my course if i see one more
person on my tick tock timeline giving
up professional advice because they have
hundreds and thousands and sometimes
even millions of dollars in their robin
hood account i swear i'm gonna rip out
my hair
that's not how you make consistent
income in the stock market you're gonna
turn a hundred dollars into a million
dollars in one year
this is very doable but you have to
learn how to trade with proper risk